well it's being said that rioting broke
out in louisville over the grand jury's
decision the brianna taylor case but
that's wrong on two levels for one the
chaos in louisville
as in so many other cities across the
country is funded and
organized moments after the grand jury
returned only three counts of wanton
endangerment against one officer for
firing shots that went into a neighbor's
apartment but no charges for taylor's
death
u-hauls packed with pre-made signs and
riot shields were already on the scene
being unloaded now it's clear that
there's there's orchestration and
planning
involved also these are not mere riots
these are violent uprisings with the
clear and often stated goal
of destabilizing the government and
burning down the system
in other words it's insurrection so
rather than riots breaking out this was
another
campaign of insurrection being carried
out
and the distinction is important it's
also important
though not relevant to the
insurrectionist that the narrative
surrounding the brianna taylor case
advanced by blm and antifa and their
allies in the media
has proven to be almost entirely false
the narrative in these high-profile
police shootings is always false of
course
the only question is one of degree just
how wrong will it turn out to be
in nearly all of the high profile cases
over the past few months especially
that answer has generally varied between
extremely
and incredibly for example the narrative
around the jacob
blake uh shooting in kenosha claimed
that he was
unarmed and shot by cops while trying to
get into his car after stopping to break
up a fight
in reality he was harassing his alleged
rape victim was armed with a knife
was reaching into his ex-girlfriend's
car which he was allegedly trying to
steal
when the officer fired in the shooting
of dion k in dc we were first told that
kaye
was an unarmed child shot in the back as
it turns out he was an adult a known
gang member and was shot in the chest
while running towards officers with his
gun drawn the case of ricardo munoz in
lancaster activists told us that he was
a
a mentally disabled person randomly
gunned down outside his mother's house
some even said there were some blm
people online saying he was
an autistic child murdered by the cops
in reality munoz was 27 years old
was shot because he chased after a
police officer while wielding a large
knife
blm has gotten almost every fact of
every case
wrong going all the way back to michael
brown in 2014 he was claimed to have
been murdered with his hands up while
begging for his life
forensic evidence eyewitness reports
eventually confirmed that he was
actually shot
while assaulting a police officer and
trying to steal his weapon and this
after he had assaulted a store clerk and
committed a robbery so what about
brianna taylor
now initially it was reported that
police burst into the wrong apartment
without knocking during a botched drug
raid
and murdered taylor while she was asleep
that would be indefensible if it was
true but once again
it wasn't as kentucky attorney general
daniel cameron
explained in his press conference on
wednesday officers were serving a
legal warrant at the right location
and they did knock before entering an
independent witness corroborates that
they announced and identified themselves
upon entering the residence briana's
taylor briana teller's boyfriend kenneth
walker
opened fired on officers when police
returned fire briana taylor was hit and
killed
here's a cameron at the press conference
explaining some of this
evidence shows that officers both
knocked
and announced their presence at the
apartment
the officer's statements about their
announcement are corroborated
by an independent witness who was near
in a proximity to apartment four
in other words the warrant was not
served
as a no knock warrant when officers were
unable to get anyone to answer or open
the door to apartment 4
the decision was made to breach the door
after breaching the door sergeant
mattingly was the first
and only officer to enter the residence
sergeant mattingly identified two
individuals
standing beside one another at the end
of the hall
a male and a female in his statement
he says that the male was holding a gun
arms extended
in a shooting stance sergeant mattingly
saw the man's gun fire heard a boom
and immediately knew he was shot as a
result of feeling heat
in his upper thigh kenneth walker fired
the shot that hit sergeant mattingly
and there is no evidence to support that
sergeant mattingly
was hit by friendly fire from other
officers
now we should mention a warrant was
issued for taylor's apartment
because there was reason to suspect that
taylor or at least her apartment
was in some way involved in her criminal
ex-boyfriend's drug
drug enterprise as court documents show
taylor's car was spotted multiple times
outside of a known drug house that was
under surveillance by law enforcement
taylor is on tape reportedly referring
to the drug house
while speaking to her then boyfriend
while he was in jail
in 2016 the body of a murder victim was
allegedly found in a car rented by
taylor which she said she had lent to
her boyfriend
shortly after her death the ex-boyfriend
was again recorded in jailhouse phone
conversations claiming that taylor was
quote handling his money
the point is that the warrant was issued
for entirely valid reasons
the cops executed it according to the
law
following all the proper protocols only
opened fire after walker had begun
shooting at them
there is no basis for calling this a
murder much less a racist murder by
agents of white supremacy
it's a tragic accident a catastrophic
confluence of events many other terms
can be used to describe it
but the fact remains that officers were
serving a lawful warrant
acting within the bounds of the law and
responding with lethal force
to the lethal force being used against
them
as usual those accusing the officers of
criminal conduct have not bothered to
explain
what they might have done differently
should they have not
obtained the warrant for the apartment
in the first place despite having
credible reason to believe that it had
ties to drug trafficking
should they not have executed the
warrant should they not have or should
they have waited outside for someone to
come to the door and if the residents
refused to answer then just pack up and
go home
or should they have not returned fire
once once they were fired upon
instead you know diving to the floor or
hiding behind furniture hoping the
assailant stops before a bullet
hits one of them in the face now blm
militants if they were being honest
would actually answer
yes to all of those questions they've
made it clear that their problem with
the police
is that the police exist anything the
police do
therefore is wrong for the simple fact
the police are the ones doing it
for blm and its allies the fight against
police brutality is a fight against
policing
itself all law enforcement
is brutality in their minds and anybody
who dies at the hands of police any
black person anyway
has been murdered no matter what
regardless of context
this is the radicalism that holds our
cities hostage
the madness to which we are all supposed
to bow
it dresses itself in the garb of racial
justice it carries signs that
say things like equality but this is all
a decidedly unconvincing disguise
for their radical assault on law and
order and civilization itself
and that's what's happening and now it's
happening in louisville
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content